experiments gone wrong snake wieners and
actual footage of me getting a sponge
bath episode 2 of lovecraft country is
here with all new theories and details
to break down in this video we'll be
diving into the mystery behind
atticus's true ancestry artem's secret
society and don't even get me started on
how adorable these baby show goths are
but before we begin show me some love by
hitting that like button and subscribing
so you can get notified as soon as one
of my breakdowns comes out well it
didn't take long for george and letty to
get over their traumatic experience with
the shoghos that's because their memory
of the event has been white
at the end of episode 1 we heard a
whistle which was used to call off the
shogus but this whistle
also did that men in black thing and
they have no recollection of those
bloodthirsty
monsters this mysterious arta mansion
just so happens to have tons of clothes
for letty to try on
and all of george's favorite books it's
as if whoever wants them there
wants them to stay a particular note are
the favorite authors george recounts
algernon blackwood william hodgson and
clark ashton smith
all of them are contemporaries of h.p
lovecraft who lovecraft himself
praised in fact william hodgson's book
the house on the borderlands
makes an appearance later on in the
episode a book written in 1908 about a
man's hallucinatory account of a remote
house and his experiences with
supernatural creatures and other
dimensions sounds familiar well letty
and george can't seem to remember what
happened the previous night
atticus does he seems to be impervious
to the whistle's memory wiping power
likely because he has the blood of titus
breath white flowing through him
but we'll get to that in a bit as
resident children of the corn william
leads them to lunch we pass a few
interesting paintings this is john
trumbull's 1839 painting the last family
who perished in the deluge
depicting a family washed out to sea
foreshadowing the deaths of
two characters later in the episode the
second is renault's 1795 painting the
genius of france between
liberty and death depicting an angel in
between a lady liberty on the left and
death on the right our captives are
stuck in a similar dilemma to this angel
held captive deprived of their liberty
on the one hand
and the specter of death on the other
atticus wants to find his father but
according to william he's on an errand
and won't be back till later they get a
tour of this creepy mansion
and its founder titus braithwight fun
fact braith comes from the old irish
word for betrayer notice here this
ring a symbol of the order of the
ancient dawn the secret society we'll
learn more about in a bit
titus apparently made his fortune in
shipping which letty surmises
involved the shipping of slaves as we'll
learn later titus did own slaves
impregnating one named hannah who
happens to be a great-great-grandmother
of atticus they decide to check out the
village of artem which looks like it's
run by the amish but find on their way
their car which was completely destroyed
the other night is
totally repaired notice how artem
utilizes a lot of
red from the barn to the flowers to the
kids playing whatever the hell this is
it's all to foreshadow danger atticus
hears a whistleblown the same sound he
heard that called off the shoghos the
previous night
it was blown by this woman who holds
sway over this creepy stone
silo a silo atticus believes may hold
his father
it's important to note that the whistle
is what makes ledy and george lose their
memory but atticus is impervious to it
on their way back to the manor as if
they didn't learn anything from the
previous night
they're saved from another attack by
none other than christina braithwight
the daughter of
samuel braithwight who we'll meet in a
bit atticus is taken to samuel's lab
where samuel's own organs are being
harvested for a dinner later in the
evening
it's okay however since samuel has the
ability to heal healing letty near the
end of the episode after shooting her
here we learn of a painting based off a
biblical verse in the book of genesis
this painting however was not painted by
a joseph tanhauser as samuel suggests
it's by john miles and it's called the
naming of the animals in which adam
helps god in creation by
creating a beautiful hierarchy of all
living things that no good eve arrived
however and tempted adam throwing the
hierarchy into a mess of tribes and
nations
now samuel here believes he can find a
way back to the garden of eden where
things are perfect and he can be
immortal he needs however ticks power
the blood of his ancestors
christina locks tick in his room with a
spell tick will later communicate with
george through the walls using morse
code calling their captors
wizards we'll also get this super odd
scene where christina delivers a baby
shogoth from a cow
i'm still scratching my head as to why
this scene was put in here as it really
doesn't advance the story but it's
possible the writers are setting
something up and need us to know that
these normal animals are being used as
vessels for abominable [ __ ] that can
later be controlled by christina i think
we definitely haven't seen the last of
her tick george and letty all experience
hallucinations as part of this secret
society's evening entertainment letty
makes out with a hallucination of
atticus only to find he's got a snake
penis
we get this shot of adam and eve adam
here also having a snake penis
and some have interpreted this story
from the bible as the snake symbolizing
satan
and the forbidden fruit as insemination
i didn't learn that in sunday school
george is visited by dora his brother's
wife it's
really hinted here that dora and him had
an affair and that this affair resulted
in the birth of atticus
making george atticus's real father
george even tells montrose that atticus
is
probably not his kid something the two
of them apparently settled years ago
further proof of this is when george
tells dora about a story he's writing
involving a man who reunites with his
long lost love
and they stay together before a house
collapses on them and what happens at
the end of this episode a house
collapses and
george dies allowing him to finally be
reunited with his long-lost love
dora who died before him the final
hallucination occurs between
tick and jia remember that girl tick
called from korea last episode
that's her she's also that red alien
thing that appeared in his dreams she is
really pissed at him and i can't help
but think that her anger is directly
related to the bad things
atticus said he did while fighting in
korea we aren't exactly sure what those
bad things are yet but we'll likely find
those out in future episodes it's really
interesting to note here that in the
subtitles it says that jia
isn't speaking korean but quote the
language of adam this is also the
language she probably spoke to him in
episode one
but i don't speak korean so i can't be
100 sure later in the episode christina
says the language of adam is so tricky
that
men have died trying to wield its power
i'm wondering if the book hannah escapes
with at the end of the episode contains
more information
about this powerful language this is
likely what george called the book of
names or the book of life it's the
opposite of the book of the dead the
necronomicon tick and george are invited
to dinner
sorry letty it's boys only no girls
allowed
there george recites the laws of their
ancient order in a book he found called
bylaws and precepts of the order of the
ancient dawn by their own law
regular members must obey orders from
those deemed sons
among sons those who are direct
descendants of titus braithwight
and since atticus is the last blood heir
he orders everyone to go home
so atticus letty and george head back to
that silo where they find montrose
having just escaped and if you're
looking for some nice tear-felt reunion
between father and son
you ain't gonna get it as they make
their escape in that silver sedan from
episode 1
we learn that this particular lodge is
one of many in a much
larger secret society this one is called
the sons of adam and years ago they
failed at conjuring a spell of
immortality which
killed everyone inside except of course
hannah their escape is short-lived
however when they smash headfirst into a
force field to make matters worse
samuel shoots letty and george he ends
up healing letty to prove to atticus
that he can heal
but won't heal george until he gets
atticus's help with his spell
sponge bath time christina tells atticus
of samuel's master plan to open a portal
to eden and there's a lot of talk about
changing destiny and even a social
commentary on how atticus was made a
member
solely based on his sex while christina
can never be a member because she's a
woman i think this is setting up her
character arc since samuel dies at the
end
i'm wondering if she'll try to take over
while george is on his deathbed we learn
a bit more about montrose's past he was
beaten by his father for liking to draw
montrose would later go on to beat
atticus for his love of books
it's a sad but revelatory bit of
information showing how trauma and abuse
can pass from one generation to the next
as atticus is forced to perform in this
experiment
a slave to his situation just like his
ancestors were actual slaves to theirs
gil scott heron's poem whitey on the
moon plays a poem which depicts the
plight of african americans
unable to pay medical bills and rent
when the government is spending millions
of their tax dollars on sending white
folks to the moon we are seeing
samuel's experiment at the expense of a
black man just like the progress of
space advancement was at the expense of
millions of black americans this
sentiment is also found in james
baldwin's speech from episode 1.
if you haven't checked out my video on
that i'll leave a link in the
description
as the experiment progresses a portal
opens with garden-like flowers
suggesting the garden of eden is
on the other side but before the
experiment goes completely haywire just
like it did decades ago
attica sees his great ancestor hannah
visibly pregnant on the other side we
also see this black
smoke-like essence emanate from
atticus's ring this seems to be the
energy that turns the others into stone
but why it comes out of the ring and why
it didn't turn atticus into stone
remains to be seen we do know that it
was charlotte who gave him this ring
leading me to believe she played a role
in sabotaging her father's plan
as retribution for keeping her on the
sidelines her entire life
because she's a woman i also just really
enjoyed the juxtaposition of atticus and
his great ancestor
escaping the home as it's destroyed in
their respective times but even though
atticus makes it out alive he finds out
his
uncle has passed leaving us wondering
what the heck will happen next now there
is an episode 3 preview which i've left
a link to in the description below
but even after watching that i'm still
scratching my head what the whole series
is working towards
thanks for watching everyone please make
sure to like and subscribe i'm planning
on breaking down
every episode of the series i'm also
interested to hear your thoughts in the
comments below
you can also follow me on twitter at
thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much